[Music]
did you guys go to Chuck E Cheese going
up yeah
San Jose had the best one San Jose had
the best Chuck E Cheese because it was a
huge [ __ ] building like imagine like
um it wasn't Peter Piper or whatever mmm
the Peter one the wannabe Chucky Cheese
the Peter Piper well this was like it
looked like it was like four stories
high was [ __ ] huge and then it was
facing the freeway and then they had a
giant story it was massive well I mean
like only the first floor was in use but
they had like a giant like three-story
high Chuckie Cheese figure you know
whatever on the side of the wall on the
building on the side of the building and
like just like a it's in the it's
enclosed in glass and you just see it on
the freeway when you're driving past
every time so every time I saw it I
scream until I got to go in there and
then like it was [ __ ] huge it was the
best Chucky Cheese ever and then I
remember I got a bit older and I move
down to SoCal and my little cousin was
like I want to go so I took him and I
realized that every other Chuckie Cheese
is [ __ ] [ __ ] oh you ruined that
ruined actually I stopped going to Chuck
E Cheese when I was a kid because in
school it was a week where you supposed
to learn about manners like I'm sorry
thank-yous and stuff like that
I got like Chucky was in his [ __ ]
outfit dancing and I went up there and I
danced next to him cuz I was a little
kid he stepped on my toe oh and I looked
at him I was like he didn't know me and
then from that point I was like [ __ ] you
and I never went back he didn't even
know ya those big-ass feet oh I didn't
know you should have paid closer
attention I went to Chuck E Cheese but
then I got scared because of the purple
girl and guy looked at scary cuz he look
like the guy of my dreams who haunted me
every night but then also I found out
later that he wasn't actually a gorilla
and he was actually shadow man and wants
me okay I always get confused cuz isn't
there a purple guy and McDonald's yeah
the grimace
and also I was terrifying like who
decided this was a good idea a giant
purple chicken nugget with like a hollow
blessed yo the giant purple Christmas
McDonald random elf it's cute at
McDonald's I didn't know his name
the V I don't know what chuck-e-cheese
is it's a chain Shane Dawson did a whole
conspiracy thing on it years ago and it
got a long estimated the conspiracy was
that they were reusing uneaten pizza to
like make up like a whole new pie it was
uneven look at some time that was uneven
look at all uneven yeah yeah it's based
off of two images but it's fine so a lot
of people go cuz it's a restaurant you
can eat and then they also have a ton of
like games like like arcade games
jungle gyms and [ __ ] time through the
tubes and you wait for your parents will
look at you at the window but they never
[ __ ] look at they're arguing PETA was
delicious but I don't know if it's so
nice it actually is better now Dax I
have like gourmet pizzas like for adults
like they got like the regular cheese
pizza for the kids and pepperoni but
they're for the adults they have like a
spinach and artichoke I know bro a kid
like having a kid's birthday party and
everyone has the pizza pizza in one
child's life I'll have a salad the
[ __ ] crossbow and shoot that kid
right now I've never heard anybody
describe a salad as bomb even though
they made a bomb it's a salad bar and I
made my own [ __ ] it was really I never
no Cheesecake Factory hey you never know
Cheesecake warehouse
they got [ __ ] bomb ass hours bro
really what's your favorite one I like
the the Asian chicken one do you cuz I
feel like you just said that cuz that's
what I ordered for lunch what no you
ordered the oriental
it's okay I'm being bastard I say it's
okay you usually order the Cobb salad
brah I usually do telling you oh so
you're alive sometimes a good what's
your favorite now do you want to know
it's because of the [ __ ] didn't they put
those crisps in the Asian chicken ones
and it's a good but I can't have it
anymore so normally I do get the call
but my favorite is the Asian one that's
a krob krob the cop the crop salad I
love salad they have cranberries do you
like a 7 year old white lady I can't
wait to see her get home and start
knitting the sit watts emergency well do
Chili's and uh they you know people come
in and they think they're being healthy
or their salads salads where more
calories than the bucket in branch
I'm sure inch that [ __ ] not anemic two
thousand calories yeah and when you look
at the Cheesecake itself they're like a
thousand dollars I'm like how the [ __ ]
is a sounds worse you know it's my least
favorite thing about coming to LA was I
you know like a salad dressing iceberg
salad you ever like a TGI Friday or
something somebody orders the website
but it comes out and you're like why
didn't I get that I drink you have that
Ruth's Chris and you get that wedge
salad come on
oh my god in the way that they just
drizzle the dressing over add a little
bit of bacon crisp absolutely no cheese
dressing okay anyway chubby cheeks
tuck it to you cheap [ __ ] chunky then
mannerless [ __ ] took the cheese I'm a
birthday yes Joe song okay so in
Portland a woman is now suing Chuckie
Cheese after she claims that her
Bernbach hot in the ticket counting
Commission's is she one of those weird
people with very long hair that goes
past the head no I don't like that cuz
I'm like it's not straight or curly it's
just a weird wave that she had to put
her hand on that she's okay she wrap the
hair around someone else dick ticket
absolutely this is an American
businesswoman really she's doing for
$1,000 oh you're just trying to get the
lace let's try to get seed money for her
business that's barely more than small
claims yeah so you guys don't know how
these ticket machines work what happens
is they give you tickets when you win
that's the freaking machines right so
you got all these tickets back in the
day these to waive the tickets in a bowl
and that's how they would count your
tickets but now they actually have a
ticket feeding machine that's like it
suctions it up and so that's how you
count your chicken vending machine
dollar that you just she used to go and
it counts
so she's claiming that her hair got cut
and she was stuck in this machine for 20
minutes
well the employees were trying to figure
it out so she's suing claiming that
chucky cheese could have done a lot more
to prevent this and so she wants like I
said 1,000 dollars in damages and she
wants a warning sign place next to the
machine so this won't happen to anyone I
don't have anyone else like the [ __ ]
were you doing we got our hands look and
we're making a scene the amount of money
that you're gonna spend on an attorney
if they do take this exactly that's not
gonna be worth it twenty minutes is so
sick dude I got stuck in my friend's
bathroom I played us live for way more
than 20 minutes that's true yeah and
it's just because of her don't even
notice I don't know
nobody even knew I was like you know
cause like god [ __ ] dammit I went in
there to pee and it seemed like a
definitely whatever vows like my lips
like my pants up for some reason the
[ __ ] door it just would not for real
it's sure I got stuck in there but there
was someone directly on the other side
and they pulled it open but then later
when Steve would to go the bathroom we
were all having a good time
in the and they're playing and they're
playing music at it so nobody even knew
I was we were like karaoke I should sue
that tried to sue their hotel for
[ __ ] emotionalize damages they're
absolutely a break
that was me stuck in that machine I
woulda just started rattling off all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] I lose brain cells I
wanna start having a panic attack
anxiety panic disorder panic disorder I
wake up at night I feel like my hair
they call it the ticket muncher you know
it was like I hear the noise at night
I'm wondering where it's coming from
this has changed my life forever I don't
think you've got an accurate reading my
tickets a quarter million dollars
embarrassing right yeah motional damage
yeah everyone saw me they laughed at me
they called me ticket head she did say
that the several injuries including pain
discomfort distress and headaches and so
she says like now should just have I
don't understand how she came up with
$1,000 was she just like she has a
specific feel that's exactly if that
wasn't the holders will she meets the
pain that's it
shouldn't think any further than that
thousand dollars is tight though I will
say getting just a grand all of a sudden
it's pretty tight maybe I don't think
she thought it through
they might just maybe she was thinking
they'll just hand over some hush money
you know like rip the band-aid off hand
it over
you're gonna start higher than that yeah
I end up at a thumb shucky Jesus I felt
even a grand isn't even registered in
yeah so chuck-e-cheese what they ended
up doing is recommending her to reach
out to their insurance company but the
insurers refused to pay so she's now
saying it's left me no choice but to sue
the company it left me no choice but to
go to the ticket counter and demand they
give me whichever
either my one big guys a big ticket item
I want the TVs please
give me the 32 inch LCD TVs like the
moment that I got the email back from
the insurance people denying me I felt
immediate trauma pain and now I mean
also the karaoke machine as well aware
and unlimited pizza at all locations
would I need a black card yes a black
card district we'd be purple purple card
oh yeah I don't know man having cheese
in a minute Oh actually the last thing
was Isaac's friend had a birthday party
there and I was like I can never return
if I don't need to because it smells
like feet yeah it smells like sweat I
used to yearned for that smell because
we didn't have one in Santa Barbara you
had to drive all the way to Ventura to
get to a Chuckie Cheese so it's like a
30-minute Drive which is like insane for
a Santa Barbara person and so I only
went like maybe two or three times in my
life and like every time I went I would
just like romanticize what it you would
it was like and getting in there I was
like oh what I remember yeah what does
that dear one for like adults like there
made like some what's called Buster's no
but I'm saying like with the ball in the
crop but it's just maybe like super big
discovery zone bro I mean that was when
I was like young but I needed for adults
I need it the same one give it to me
Queen I remember discovery is Arthur
yeah
every places on my let's slide with the
flame I should hurt thingy I loved it
those the [ __ ] was that
the rollers are we doing the same thing
you're [ __ ] weird charlie like salads
anything some massage you're like yeah
like ninety years old when you were born
and actually private myself a lot in the
fact that I was really weird yeah good
for you you know I'm like to my friends
people would always tell me like you're
weird in a like yeah I should go up to
be will be I'm weird I meant thank you
some of us were like I'm normal I'm
normal I'm normal he's like me except me
yeah just like so what stops you guys
have keep playing time out of the can
may or doesn't yeah this is kind of
healthy for you this I started doing it
[Music]